Merci, c’est super sympa, parce que là, je n’en pouvais plus de la ville.
J’ai besoin de déconnecter.
Y a pas de soucis.
En plus la saison d’avant, ça s’est super mal passé,
je me suis brouillé avec les autres, on s’est tous brouillé.
Du coup, niveau loyer, comme ils sont tous partis, c’est super compliqué.
Nan mais vraiment, c’est vraiment cool de ta part.
T’inquiètes, tu m’aideras au jardin en plus.
Tu sais moi, en plus, je viens de la campagne , ce silence va tellement me faire du bien...
Qu’est ce que !
Mais qu’est ce qu’il fait là lui ?
Quoi ?
Ouais, elles m’ont loué la petite maison d’en face.
T’inquiète, je les ai eu au tel, elles sont super sympas.
C’est des connasses.
Quel est le point commun entre la Lozère, le Cantal et la Nièvre?
Vous l’aurez deviné : ils sont situés dans la diagonale du vide, perdent chaque année des habitants alors que la France en gagne pourtant,
les jeunes s’en barrent dès qu’ils peuvent ce qu’il fait qu’on y trouve proportionnellement plus de vieux qu’ailleurs.
Et ces jeunes, ils se barrent en ville.
En France, ils sont désormais majoritaires à y vivre, et comme c’est la période de la vie où l’on se marie,
on s’attendrait naturellement à ce que les mairies urbaines soient prises d’assaut et accusent le coup
face à tous les néocitadins désireux d’officialiser leurs relations.
Surtout qu’en principe, le mariage est célébré dans une commune où l’un des deux époux doit justifier d’une résidence continue d’au moins un mois.
Mais il n’en est rien.
C’est l’autre point commun entre la Lozère, le Cantal et la Nièvre.
Ce sont des territoires prisés pour les mariages.
Si tous les jeunes se barrent en région parisienne pour chercher du boulot,
les franciliens quant à eux se barrent à la campagne pour se marier.
Et pour se confiner aussi, mais ça c’est autre chose.
Vous l’aurez compris : dans cet épisode, on va parler d’exode rural, de reproduction humaine, de retour à la terre aussi, et de fracture territoriale évidemment.
Et pour commencer, peut-être que l’on peut se rafraichir nos cours d’histoire de collège :
c’est quoi, l’exode rural ?
Comme son nom l’indique assez brutalement, c’est le fait de se barrer des campagnes pour rejoindre les villes.
C’est une dynamique très ancienne que l’on constatait déjà en Egypte antique.
En Europe, une dynamique d’exode rural a débuté dès le Moyen-âge avec l’urbanisation.
On trouve en ville les places publiques avec des boutiques,
on y construit les cathédrales et les universités,
on y développe des services, de nouveaux secteurs économiques et un milieu culturel qui rendent l’endroit attrayant.
Évidemment, les capitales sont les plus prisées.
Par ailleurs, la centralisation en un seul point de l’activité économique devient un enjeu important en France avec la révolution industrielle,
qui nécessite de grosses infrastructures et une importante main-d'œuvre, et dont la production doit être proche des voies de transport.
Les villes ne cessent alors de séduire : les salaires y sont meilleurs, on y est plus ouverts, on y trouve de meilleurs écoles et parfois même les seules dans leur genre,
on y associe aussi l’idée que l’on y est moins impacté par le déterminisme social et que l’on peut partir de zéro pour gravir l’échelle sociale.
Puis, les jeunes n’ont d’autre choix que de monter en ville pour des emplois journaliers ou saisonniers quand la saison est creuse, aussi.
C’est un peu la version locale du rêve américain.
Par ailleurs, en s’étendant, les villes grignotent les terres rurales, ce qui impacte fortement ceux qui y vivent et les force soit à partir, soit à se convertir à ce nouveau mode de vie.
Mais ça, on en reparlera après.
Non mais tu vois, ça débarque de la ville l’air de rien,
mais si tu laisses faire, après tu as un Biocoop à la place du bistrot au village !
Y a pas de bistrot au village.
Bah voilà, qu’est ce que je te disais.
Tu ne veux pas arrêter de râler et m’aider à arroser ?
C’est ça mon mode de vie en fait, et je t’avoue que si tu t’y pliais un peu, ça m’arrangerait bien.
Mais quand même.
En France, l’exode rural débute vraiment dans la seconde partie du 19e siècle.
Il n’est absolument pas uniforme, des territoires sont plus touchés que d’autres.
C’est surtout les régions montagneuses et le Sud de la France qui sont impactés.
En effet, la terre y est plus difficile à exploiter, et ses travailleurs sont donc plus fortement affectés par les fluctuations des rendements agricoles et de leur valeur économique.
d’un côté, l’augmentation de la productivité diminue les besoins de main-d'œuvre, tout en augmentant la taille des exploitations.
De l’autre, les crises agricoles viennent sonner le glas dans beaucoup de régions.
La crise de 1880 due au Phylloxéra par exemple, un insecte s’attaquant aux vignes,
met de nombreux ouvriers agricoles et petits paysans hors-jeu, et ceux-là n’ont d’autre choix que de partir.
Par effet boule de neige, ces départs en provoquent d’autres.
L’artisanat local voit sa clientèle réduire, et nombreux sont les artisans qui alors empruntent le même chemin.
Comme cet exode touche avant tout une population en âge de se reproduire, une baisse de la natalité vient enfoncer un peu plus le clou.
En France, la part de la population vivant en ville devient donc majoritaire en 1931, cela ne fait donc pas si longtemps que ça.
La Bretagne, où nous nous sommes reclus pour tourner cette vidéo, a fait les frais de cet exode.
Les crises agricoles ne l’ont pas épargnée, et il s’y est ajouté l'effondrement des manufactures textiles à base de lin ou de chanvre qui ont souffert de la concurrence du coton.
Et puis avec la mécanisation de la marine, marquant la fin des bateaux à voile,
la demande s’est effondrée.
Avec la ligne de chemin-de-fer Brest-Paris inaugurée en 1865,
beaucoup de Bretons partent et atterrissent à Montparnasse, dans le 14e arrondissement de Paris,
qui devient le quartier breton.
Terre très catholiques, certains décident aussi de quitter la Bretagne pour fuir le poids de la religion.
Les hommes deviennent ouvriers et les femmes deviennent bonniches,
si bien que cela inspire le personnage de Bécassine, la bonne Bretonne vue par la bourgeoisie parisienne.
Pour les émigrés issus de la province, comme on dit si bien à Paris, ce n’est pas toujours facile à vivre.
Il y a le bruit auquel on est peu habitué, la densité de population, et surtout la méfiance et le mépris qui sont souvent de rigueur.
Les Bretons se retrouvent avec les Kabyles et les Auvergnats subissant le même sort, pour s’entraider.
Les Savoyards, dont la région est annexée par la France en 1860 mais qui auparavant déjà se vidait au profit de la région parisienne et de la région lyonnaise,
sont particulièrement ciblés par la xénophobie.
À Paris, on les traite d’étranger et on les accuse de voler le travail des locaux,
et comme ils ne parlent pas toujours le français de Paris, ni français tout court d’ailleurs, la glottophobie est souvent au rendez-vous.
A l’époque, on emploie le mot savoyard pour désigner un homme sale, grossier ou brutal, rustre et peu commode.
Le sous-préfet de Saint-Julien-en-Genevois en Haute-Savoie, dans son rapport du 8 juin 1874, ira même jusqu’à écrire qu’”il existe une conspiration permanente”
et que “les Savoyards se soutiennent, tous s’entendent, du premier au dernier”
et qu’il faut alors les assimiler.
Pour éviter que le contraire ne se passe j’imagine. Evidemment.
Aujourd’hui, la plupart des français ignorent alors que cette Savoie aujourd’hui bien à nous,
là où on descend depuis l’autoroute A6 pour aller faire du ski,
elle était considérée comme une région rustre et étrangère dont les habitants arriérés venaient récurer nos chiottes en ville.
Les salauds !
Parce que ce sont nos emplois, nom de dieu ! N’avez-vous pas honte de nous voler notre travail ! Celui des honnêtes français !
Un discours que l’on peut entendre en Savoie désormais, preuve de sa bonne intégration dans la magnifique république française.
Alors l’exode, il a changé au cours des années, touchant une région puis l’autre, sans toutefois s’arrêter.
Après la Seconde Guerre mondiale, c’est surtout l’ouest qui en fait les frais, ou encore l’intérieur de la corse qui perd 90% de sa population entre 1960 et 1990.
C’est beaucoup.
Il existe même des régions pour lesquelles l’exode rural fut au début un avantage, comme la Lorraine et le Nord de la France
qui ont bénéficié de l’industrialisation.
Dotés de bassin miniers, l’exploitation du charbon, de l’acier et leur exploitation dans l’industrie lourde ont permis d’avoir une croissance démographique positive
même si leurs campagnes se sont aussi vidées
Les départs étaient largement compensés par les arrivées.
Sauf qu’aujourd’hui, ces régions autrefois porteuses d’une activité économique nécessaire et même stratégique
se prennent dans la gueule la désindustrialisation.
Désormais, c’est les Nordistes et les Lorrains qui fuient leurs régions et à qui on associe les clichés autrefois réservés aux Savoyards, aux Bretons ou aux Auvergnats.
Depuis quelque temps d’ailleurs, Savoie et Bretagne sont devenues des terres d’accueil.
Le département de Haute-Savoie est même désormais le département français le plus dynamique démographiquement parlant,
et il compte maintenant plus de 800.000 habitants.
C’est trois fois plus qu’en 1946.
Si l’Est et le Nord se vident désormais, le sud de la France et la façade Atlantique refont le plein.
Bref, ce qui est attractif aujourd’hui étaient peut-être les régions que l’on fuyaient hier, et vice versa.
Cette inversion de paradigme est très présente en Belgique, d’ailleurs.
La Wallonie autrefois si riche prenait la Flandre paysanne de haut, désormais ce sont les premiers qui passent pour les pouilleux et les seconds pour des bourgeois.
Par ailleurs, impact spécifique à ce pays, l’exode rural wallon contribuera à la francisation de Bruxelles, qui était une ville de langue flamande il y a encore un siècle.
Tu vois moi par exemple, je viens de l’Est.
On passe pour des arriérés maintenant.
Alors oui, je suis parti, je n’ai pas eu le choix.
Et du coup, je suis venue m’installer ici parce que c’est vachement plus sympa quoi.
C’est un peu la situation que je suis en train de vivre maintenant quoi.
C’est-à-dire ?
Je suis sûr que bientôt, j’vais pas avoir le choix non plus, et je vais aller faire un tour à la maison d’en face,
parce que ça a l’air vachement plus cool que t’entendre te plaindre.
Et d’ailleurs, je vais y aller. Bonne chance avec les légumes.
Mais du coup, assiste-t-on à une revitalisation des campagnes ?
En fait, oui mais non.
Tout d’abord, les campagnes restent relativement peu attractives.
Si vous voulez une école, un accès à une gare, un service de transport en commun ou encore un hôpital où vous soigner,
il existe chaque année de moins en moins de communes disposées à vous fournir ces services.
Eh oui, la raréfaction des services publics se poursuit encore, et elle fait effet de répulsif sur les actifs
qui sont ceux qui soutiennent souvent le gros de l’activité économique d’une région,
que ce soit par la force de travail ou par les recettes fiscales.
Quitte à s’installer quelque part alors, autant éviter que ce soit pour voir la fermeture de la maternité,
un regroupement scolaire conduisant à un déplacement de l’école ou encore le démantèlement de la dernière ligne de chemin-de-fer.
Du coup, les jeunes continuent de se tirer des bleds,
et ceux qui s’installent ne sont pas forcément ceux qui peuvent régler le problème structurel de la baisse démographique.
Ils n’ont pas le même âge ni les mêmes besoins.
L’impact sur la natalité n’est souvent pas perceptible.
En France, il existe un phénomène d’héliotropisme, c’est-à-dire de migration des personnes âgées vers les territoires ensoleillés,
pour y passer une belle retraite.
Un phénomène qui attire des vieux d’ailleurs, au passage, comme les Anglais qui viennent vivre pépère en Dordogne.
Or, la priorité des vieux c’est pas d’avoir une école dans le village, c’est plutôt d’avoir un ehpad par exemple.
Si on en trouve relativement peu à Paris, les départements ruraux en sont bien dotés.
En France, les ehpad privés sont sans surprise surtout répartis le long de la côte-d’Azur.
Si l’arrivée du numérique et du télétravail aurait pu représenter une aubaine pour redynamiser les campagnes, elle a eu l’effet inverse.
À  l’heure où les habitants des villes parlent de la fibre, ceux qui peuplent nos villages n’ont encore parfois pas l’ADSL.
2,4 millions de foyers français n’ont même pas un demi-méga seconde de connexion, c’est-à-dire presque rien finalement,
et 600.000 vivent carrément en zone blanche.
En 2017, 90% des parisiens avaient accès au très haut-débit contre 1% des habitants de la Creuse ou de la Dordogne.
Ils sont vraiment sans gêne ces citadins de ses morts.
Mais attend mais c’est Arnaud !
Arnaud de StupidEco.
Et bah dites voir, elle va être fun cette semaine.
Franchement, mais pourquoi ceux qui y restent décident d’y rester dans ces conditions ?
Faut partir. Faut pas rester.
Benoit Coquard, sociologue, a justement écrit un ouvrage appelé “ceux qui restent”, qui se confondent souvent avec ceux qui disent “c’était mieux avant”.
Pour beaucoup, c’est parce qu’ils n’ont pas pu partir, tout simplement.
Par manque de réussite scolaire, par manque de relations, par manque de moyens mais aussi parce que l’ancrage familial ou territorial était trop fort,
pour perpétuer l’histoire familiale aussi.
Ceux qui restent, c’est aussi ceux qui voient les autres partir et qui vivent un déclassement social qui tranche avec les générations précédentes.
Leurs parents ou grands-parents, durant les trente glorieuses, avaient des perspectives d’avenir et des emplois stables.
Mais ça, c’était le bon temps.
Chez les jeunes qui restent, c’est le coup dur.
Quand on ne peut pas se déplacer, quand y’a pas de cinéma, de loisirs, et que toute activité s’inscrit dans un environnement social limité et donc que tout le monde connaît tout le monde,
l’ennui est souvent omniprésent.
Et par ennui, les adolescents cassent des panneaux et crament des poubelles.
C’est aussi con que ça.
Ils boivent, aussi.
A la campagne, on boit plus et on boit plus jeune, par ennui souvent là aussi.
C’est l’un des rares moyens de sociabilisation.
Il y a deux fois plus de jeunes de 17 ans à boire régulièrement de l’alcool à la campagne qu’en région parisienne.
Et moins de personnes, c’est moins de candidats possibles à la reproduction.
C’est très cru dit comme ça, mais c’est la vérité.
La sexualité, celle des jeunes filles notamment, est un enjeu de lutte très tôt.
Au collège, la séparation entre les filles qui “couchent” et les autres est très forte.
Et dans cette lutte, si l’on trouve des garçons du même âge, on en trouve également des plus vieux.
Et tout se sait.
Une bagnole garée à tel endroit ou un scooter qui passe dans telle rue, c’est certain, machin couche avec truc.
Les rencontres se font via un réseau limité de personnes, et vos parents savent qui vous fréquenter avant que vous ayez la chance de leur en parler.
Les étiquettes sont vite collées, les réputations sont vite forgées. Elles collent à la peau.
Même des années plus tard, une fois bien installé avec la ptite famille.
De manière générale, à la campagne, on couche plus tôt.
La part des moins de 15 ans ayant eu un rapport sexuel y est plus forte.
Cette pression au dépucelage touche avant tout les garçons, qui sont plus nombreux à coucher plus jeune.
Cela crée d’autant plus de déception : rétrospectivement, ils auraient aimé couché plus tard.
Quant aux jeunes filles de cet âge, qui souvent fréquentent des hommes plus vieux,
elles disent fréquemment qu’elles n’avaient pas vraiment envie de relations sexuelles.
Il faut dire que dans un monde où l’hétérosexualité n’est jamais remise en question, il est suspect de ne pas avoir été en couple passé 16 ou 17 ans.
Le célibat est une preuve d’un manque de valeur sur le marché conjugal, l’injonction pour se mettre en couple est donc très forte.
Cette pression, à mesure que les couples se forment autour de nous,
est d’autant plus forte les études terminées, puis dans la vie active.
Dans un territoire à faible population, quand on est dans ceux qui restent, il ne faut surtout pas finir dans les derniers célibataires,
c’est localement identifié comme un problème, et pour le résoudre…
il faut faire avec les mecs ou les meufs qui restent.
Bref, à la campagne, le couple s’installe et cohabite plus rapidement.
Beaucoup doivent un temps vivre chez les parents de l’un des partenaires, ce qui renforce l’exclusivité sexuelle et l’engagement conjugal.
Pour beaucoup de jeunes femmes, le couple permet l’indépendance vis-à-vis de sa propre famille, l’accès à de nouveaux lieux de socialisation et une forme de reconnaissance sociale localement.
Plus fortement confrontées au chômage et à la précarité, les femmes cherchent surtout les hommes plus âgés et déjà insérés sur le marché du travail et se dédient alors souvent à un projet maternel.
En revanche, un homme rural sans expérience professionnelle a peu de chance de connaître la vie de couple.
Par ailleurs, les femmes rurales sont aussi moins disposées à quitter leur partenaire, de par les impacts sociaux et économiques qui sont souvent préjudiciables.
De fait, elles sont plus exposées aux violences conjugales.
Y a un truc super intéressant dans le film « Les Filles du Docteur March »,
où le personnage d’Amy dit que le mariage est une question économique.
Et ça, c’est un truc qu’on voit quand Gary Becker a commencé à parler du mariage, il en a parlé comme d’un marché.
C’était dans les années 70, où quelque chose comme ça.
Et quand tu reviens dans les époques, que ce soit avec la dot ou la douaire,
à chaque fois, tu vois que quand il y a un mariage ou une mise en couple,
y a de la thune qui est échangée.
Ça va dans tous les sens.
Ça peut aller de la famille de la mariée vers la famille du marié, de la famille des mariés vers les autres mariées, vers les nouveaux mariés,
ça va vraiment dans tous les sens, mais à chaque fois,
il y a de la thune qui est échangée.
Et ça montre bien un truc, c’est que le mariage, c’est un truc économique.
Pourtant, avant ça, les économistes ont mis vraiment du temps à s’y intéresser.
Alors que ça touche à plein de sujets intéressants.
Que ce soit la démographie, l’allocation du temps libre
ou même les inégalités de revenu et de patrimoine.
Nan mais, ça t’intéresse ce que je dis ?
Tout à l’heure, j’ai suggéré qu’il y aurait une revitalisation des campagnes.
Et c’est vrai, en partie. A condition de pas être trop loin d’une ville, accessible par le train ou l’autoroute.
Et de pas être trop tatillon sur le sens du mot “revitalisation”, aussi.
Parce qu’aujourd’hui, vivre en ville coûte cher.
Super cher, même.
A Paris, se loger coûte en moyenne 1065€ par mois, alors que le SMIC net perçu en France est de 1219€.
Comme les bailleurs demandent au moins 3 fois votre loyer en salaire, le calcul est vite fait : impossible de combiner salaire minimum et centre-ville.
Pourtant, que ce soit Paris ou une autre,
la ville a besoin de ses éboueurs, de ses femmes de ménage, de ses caissières, de ses travailleurs sociaux, de ses guichetiers, de ses vendeurs… bref,
les centres urbains ont besoin de personnel qui ne peut pas se permettre de vivre sur place.
Il lui faut alors vivre autour : c’est la périurbanisation.
Ainsi, chaque métropole en France est associée à un territoire qui fait office de réservoir et de dortoir.
Le foncier y est moins cher, les impôts locaux également, et chacun peut y avoir sa petite maison individuelle avec son jardinet.
Désormais, c’est alors là que l’essentiel de la croissance démographique française est désormais concentrée.
Si les gens fuient la ville alors, c’est pour s’installer dans sa bordure sans pour autant cesser d’y travailler.
Il se forme autour des centre-villes des couches en oignon,
à la première couronne succède la deuxième, puis la troisième, la quatrième couronne…
le cercle grandit, et le bord est toujours plus loin du centre qui reste néanmoins le point de convergence.
Aujourd’hui, l’espace périurbain couvre 38% du territoire français métropolitain, pour un même pas un quart de la population française qui y habite.
Nous sommes donc les champions d’Europe de l’étalement urbain, et loin devant les autres, genre loin.
La périurbanisation est problématique sur le plan social, parce qu’elle gentrifie les territoires absorbés par l’agglomération urbaine.
Des habitants plus favorisés s’y installent,
provoquant une augmentation du coût de la vie localement et donc une fuite des premiers habitants qui ne peut plus se permettre de rester,
les ouvriers en premier.
La gentrification peut aussi conduire à la mort des petits commerces indépendants, qui pâtissent de l’augmentation de la valeur immobilière par une augmentation des loyers,
sans pour bénéficier de la richesse des nouveaux arrivants qui préfèrent d’autres commerces plus branchés.
Elle s’accompagne aussi de l’effet Nimby,
“not im my backyard”
c’est-à-dire “pas dans mon arrière-cour”.
Le nimbiste, car c’est là le nom qu’on lui donne, va s’opposer à certaines politiques locales ou encore à l’implantation de certaines infrastructures
pour ne pas en subir ce qu’il perçoit comme un effet négatif
tout en profitant de leurs existences.
C’est ainsi que les nuisances sont déplacés dans les régions moins favorisées, que les industries polluantes sont implantées dans les régions les plus pauvres,
et que les aéroports qui desservent les villes ou que les éoliennes qui les alimentent se retrouvent en réalité à proximité de petits villages qui ne l’ont souvent pas voulu et qui n’en bénéficient pas directement,
ou encore que les populations défavorisées sont poussées à partir là où elles ne tâcheront plus le paysage.
L’impact est aussi environnemental.
Les villes étant installées au cœur des régions fertiles, l’agrandissement de leurs banlieues et l’artificialisation des sols de leur périphérie réduit les terres agricoles disponibles.
Comme les périurbains travaillent en ville alors qu’ils sont forcés de vivre de plus en plus loin de ce lieu de travail,
les déplacements quotidiens convergents banlieue-ville augmentent.
Alors du coup, tu as des impacts sur l’environnement de la périurbanisation.
Le premier qui me vient à l’esprit, qui est peut-être le plus évident, c’est l’artificialisation des milieux et la fragmentation des habitats.
Quand tu construis des logements ou des infrastructures pour les transports, forcément tu empiètes sur des milieux plus ou moins naturels, qu’ils soient terrestres ou aquatiques.
Et dans ce cas-là, soit ça ruine tout un écosystème, soit ils sont seulement perturbés ou dégradés.
Ça entraîne aussi des obstacles à la libre circulation de la faune et de la flore, avec des barrières lumineuses, sonores ou physiques,
Ça, je t’en parlerais un autre jour parce que j’ai vraiment beaucoup de trucs à dire là-dessus.
Quand tu parles d’obstacles, tu parles par exemple,
ce qui me vient en tête, c’est les voies de chemin de fer, typiquement les voies de TGV ou vraiment, on a clôturé sur les côtés parce que la haute vitesse fait que le gibier ne peut pas passer ou ce genre de trucs.
Ouais, c’est ça, et du coup, tu peux avoir des aménagements qui passent par-dessus, c’est ce qu’on appelle des écoducs,
ou dessous pour les amphibiens, par exemple.
Moi quand tu me dis ça, ça me fait penser à un truc.
Peut-être que je me trompe, peut-être que j’ai mal lu.
Mais ils me semblent avoir lu que le Rhône et la Seine, comme c’est relativement bétonisées comme berges, ont tendance à plus facilement déborder.
Exactement. C’est l’imperméabilisation des sols. On accélère la circulation des eaux
et on se retrouve avec des problèmes de ruissellement, et souvent d’inondation.
Et des sols bétonnés, c’est aussi des sols qui stockent beaucoup moins de carbone.
Et comme tu l’expliquais aussi tout à l’heure, tu as des augmentations de trajets domicile-travail,
qui du coup entraînent des émissions de CO2, et la qualité de l’air s’en retrouve aussi impactée.
Tu ajoutes à cela d’éventuels problèmes de pollution via des déchets, pollutions des eaux,
pollution paysagère avec le mitage, la périurbanisation touche pas mal la biodiversité.
Quand tu as des projets d’aménagement qui
peuvent dégrader la biodiversité, tu peux aussi avoir des mesures compensatoires,
mais souvent les dégâts occasionnés sont irréversibles et n’ont fait qu’aggraver l’état de conservation de certaines espèces, qui sont déjà pas en très bon état.
Coup dur pour les espèces.
Bon, du coup si vous croisez des mariés un peu friqués au bled, ce sont certainement des citadins qui viennent profiter du cadre bucolique.
Et peut-être même qu’ils viendront s’installer à la campagne, rachetant un petit pavillon qui autrefois appartenait à un ouvrier qui n’a plus les moyens,
et ce sera plus vraiment la campagne mais plutôt une cité dortoir au service de la métropole dont les bords se rapprochent de plus en plus.
Bon, c’est assez cliché hein. Mais pas faux pour autant.
Si on pourrait croire que l’exode rural est aujourd’hui terminé, c’est seulement qu’il cache de nouvelles réalités qui ne résolvent pas le problème de la fracture territoriale.
Ceux qui partent et ceux qui arrivent n’ont pas les mêmes profils sociologiques, les mêmes intérêts donc.
Par exemple, que les vieux viennent passer une retraite campagnarde, cela compense peut-être les départs,
mais comme ils ne font plus de gamins et que ceux qui en font continuent de monter en ville, cela ne résout aucun problème de fond.
Eh oui, s’il y a convergence des modes de vie entre la campagne et la ville, merci internet notamment,
il demeure toujours un fossé, des inégalités, et ce n’est pas parti pour s’arranger.
Parce que oui,
avoir une maternité, une gare ou une école, à certains endroits,
ça devient un luxe et un enjeu de lutte.
Eh bien, merci d’avoir regardé cette vidéo et bien évidemment,
abonnez-vous, mettez des commentaires et des likes.
Et rejoignez-nous sur le Discord, vous pourrez trouver plein de gens sympas avec qui parler, et actuellement, je suis en direct sur Twitch pour parler de ce sujet précis,
et on va peut-être parler de ma jeunesse à la campagne, ça va être sympa.
Alors, ça avance avec les légumes ?
Comme tu vois, ça avance à son rythme.
Tu ne m’avais pas dit que c’était tes anciennes coloc du Vortex de la saison d’avant. Du coup, c’est personnel en fait.
Ca change rien ça, c’est des bourgeoises, enfin tu verras.
Je vois surtout qu’elles m’ont offert le café et qu’on a bien discuté, et qu’elles sont pas rancunières.
Rancunière de quoi ?
Non rien, mais t’as intérêt de régler tes histoires avec elles, parce que j’ai pas envie de passer des vacances dans une sale ambiance.
Parce que l’ambiance, elle est ouf là.